hello everybody my name is Mark Clark
well can do the sound effects challenge
if you've ever seen whose line is it
anyway you know how this game goes
they're going to make sounds for us I'm
going to be kidding sounds from Ryan
he's going to be getting sounds from
Matt and that matter together and then
we're going to rotate out and see if we
can't make an improv scene out of this
make sense which we didn't last time but
it was funny anyway big whopping big
watch man dropping it big on Santa's big
floppy dick well that's one of the
things to happen okay so if that didn't
make sense
I'll summarize it better later but we
got any job in the city of Los Angeles a
bank robber you finished at okay crime a
bank robber
finds out finds out before robbing a
bank
he accidentally drained laxatives oh
okay you want to be a banker I'll be the
bank robber okay
wrong number
hello can I help you sir
Oh God
oh geez walking I hope you mean business
yes it's so funny but Bert's spoke I
think I'm drinking on my blood hang on
it's really tasty I got jello blood it's
great all right that's good
all right give me all the money okay
you're hard to shop into one huh there
you go very noisy don't mind the
language change
it's just giant Mario coins that's all
we chose our son all right
I'm still bleeding profusely at the
curse but no clock is that me or you I
think
yeah you better get out here ah oh my
stomach [ __ ] my pants
well you're [ __ ] your pants I'm
dying I've gotta love 17 gunshot wound
Oh Oh
I'm stitching you up why are you see
thanks for the kisses whoa hey come on
ticklish down there so I like my garden
oh hey I'm gonna kill a sheep no I got
it first a business with you oh I should
get out what I take a lot of laxatives
so I have one here the other a glass of
this - sorry
unfortunately Oh now me just a cake
good thing the cops are gone I'm gonna
just [ __ ] all the shells out of this I
really I really don't actually want to
see you
hang on here one more thing
yeah now we're even [ __ ] are spilling
out all the laxatives I drank I my
stomach the whole my stomach that's good
because now I won't they won't go
through my digit side oh yeah
yeah everything turned out great via
you're a high school musical director
and on opening night you're the only
know Kim to be only captain under this
tube okay
it goes perfectly well nothing good
nothing goes wrong except for one thing
is all things that go wrong perfect yes
okay we're ready
no that's an earthquake there's an
earthquake okay but you go where you
want to keep the play going those are
really elaborate no matter what happens
we're trying to keep that play goodbye
Oh what who are you again I'm Ben yeah
you're Kevin I think I remember your
name hi yes
are you allowed to be talking to me I
hope so this I was just gonna say this
play is going really well and I enjoy
the word you're hanging that way Am I
okay okay I'm sorry
so oh and some of the ground is shaking
no just a leaky pipe over there okay hey
let's hi bunny hey they're going or
something we're up the creek I'm sorry
all right we're gonna quit here you take
it
just jump okay what's your first line of
this way work pause everyone
- we're supposed to be going perfectly
fine oh oh
you're [ __ ] shot [ __ ] literally and
that no no again with the ships stop
that I'm sorry we're trying to cooking
with boom I got a boner now we'll go
again I can't go on stage maybe if I get
a super boner I could turn the crowd in
our favor
how would that work oh wow that was the
door I'm going to business whole
auditorium please check the doorbell -
this school on time it's the nurse she's
here for you she's the Super Bowl okay
oh good in underwater world
oh man has to save the Titanic okay okay
this is okay circa 1910 way yeah so you
hold off your Aquaman eyes okay I'm
aquavit no you're survivor on the tech
tree there's one survivor left on the
Titanic underwater gel okay okay
you're okay man okay I'm good
that's like hey I had a guest he needed
some trouble my friend Foley oh bloody
in the room doors are sort of trying to
fight the water on oh okay I got all the
water to the phone's off so there's no
Gladys in my joints are squeaking oh I
need another air bubble for you
Brooke here's an air bubble so you can
breathe Thanks oh I just had a brain
aneurysm yeah whatever
I didn't get my signal one of my fish
friends is telling me you're the one
responsible for this disaster oh my
super motorbike war bye okay I'm gonna
run you over
tink I dropped my spoon I'm dropping all
like oh okay whoa
waves are remember surf is not how bad I
was at you oh very Ryu prop I can
probably take you here so you can
survive it and be accounted for justice
but this thing is sinking out there's a
cow on that boat and he's moving oh no
oh yeah you too on that boat get your
wheel I just cannot account for that
challenge rally
Oh No I killed a shot you while we're
growing and I'm Matthew not for stopping
July is I shall stop
I'm having the grow out of this ha
justice water glasses justice Oh boomer
hey cover me
I read all my fishy friends to attack
this man named Emmett ow ow what's going
on
Oh something's something's happening
getting scared oh no I got a boner you
got a boner I've only given a motor
energy already Santa Claus is going
through a divorce
hi but when he shows up to court oh he
is yes a baby that's not the possum drop
mrs. Glock your [ __ ] up
okay I'm mrs. Claus he's getting a
divorce but he shows up drunk with a be
okay
I can't believe then you won't let me
drink it mom look look look look look
look look
I've stressed you know those air
palpable saggy feel strippers
use made you been drinking again
oh that's stressing me out so much every
single mother someone changes baby sorry
my popper batteries use throughout the
baby sick Rudolph and I'm pregnant with
his baby
wait I'm hearing it as a friend nor me
real babies wait we're betting on me
yeah you didn't get the gist of that
hanging I'll kill this one works I feel
really high apparently you're several I
plug your one good job blood smash oh I
think boy that was a travesty wasn't it
I think we're all found ourselves and
yeah we're proud of ourselves but we're
not proud of each other you started out
strong in the first one that never ya
know why don't we all go to Applebee's
no abnormalities it makes everything
better
thank you everybody so much for watching
this was a travesty we'll never do it
again
so unless you guys want more of it so
thanks again and as always though check
these guys out in the description below
as well that as always we'll see it next
one bye bye